advertencia punto en común es un
experimento social que reúne a personas
de creencias opuestas las discusiones
podrían contener opiniones que nacen de
la desinformación recuerden consultar
expertos Y ser críticos Al momento de
formar sus propias creencias por favor
Recuerde la humanidad de cada
participante como siempre fomentamos la
empatía advertencia este video contiene
temas delicados que puede molestar
algunos espectadores dos cosas pueden
ser ciertas puede que lo hayas pasado
mal el privilegio no se limita solo a
los blancos pero decir que el privilegio
blanco no existe en la historia para mí
es con todo respeto absurdo
[Música]
punto en común
da un paso adelante si estás de acuerdo
los blancos también experimentan el
racismo
hacen creo que el racismo
definitivamente no es una carrera de
unos contra otros no importa si eres
blanco si eres negro o asiático no
importa podrías experimentar racismos
sin importar el color de tu piel creo
que las personas tienden a tener
adversión hacia lo que es diferente a
ellas me han llamado drogadicta antes me
han dicho que me iban a golpear porque
era Blanca Yo diría que a nivel
sistémico los blancos no experimentan el
racismo de la misma manera que otras
etnias experimentan el racismo pero
diría que a nivel individual cualquier
grupo también es capaz de ser racista
con otro grupo El argumento en contra de
esta posición con frecuencia es que el
racismo es un sistema no un sentimiento
en los Estados Unidos Estoy totalmente
de acuerdo con eso pero al mismo tiempo
soy judío y racialmente blanco y
definitivamente he experimentado racismo
discriminación la paradoja Es que la
mayor parte de ese racismo proviene de
los blancos o de la sociedad Europea el
nacionalismo blanco etcétera que está
dirigido a los judíos
y soy judío estoy orgulloso de ser judío
y de estar conectado a una religión y
cultura antiguas pero diría que no estoy
orgulloso de ser blanco El privilegio
blanco creo que es un aspecto de la
sociedad estadounidense creo que existe
cuando voy a una entrevista de trabajo
no tengo que preocuparme por mi peinado
ni por mi forma de hablar ni por mi
nombre eso es algo de lo que quizás una
persona negra debería preocuparse Pueden
pasar los que no están de acuerdo
solo quiero decir que quiero que validez
las experiencias individuales de todos
también creo que los blancos
experimentan prejuicios pero la razón
por la que no di un paso adelante es
porque por definición
el racismo está ligado al poder y a la
economía tú hablaste de discriminación
sistemática no siento que los blancos
experimenten el racismo por definición y
por concepto real Cuál es la definición
del racismo y Quién escribió esa
definición a finales de 1500 principios
de 1600 había esclavitud comenzaron a
traer esclavos pero realmente no existía
el concepto de clasificar a las personas
en términos de raza es solo que estamos
trayendo a estas personas y son esclavos
lo que terminó sucediendo es que algunos
de los dueños esclavos que eran blancos
comenzaron a mezclarse con algunos de
los Esclavos Ahora aquí tienes a estas
personas negras que se parecen a las
personas que son dueñas de cosas y fue
como bueno espera la teoría de la raza
se formó para clasificar a un grupo de
personas que serían menores y tendrían
menos poder económico esa no ha sido la
experiencia Blanca en el país pero no
invalida las cosas que experimentan los
blancos Simplemente no es racismo por
definición es prejuicio está mal sí
siempre Si una persona trata otra de
manera diferente por el color de su piel
y para mí eso es racismo te diré que la
policía me detuvo muchas veces cuando
era joven también les diré que decidí
trabajar 35 años como policía también
les diré que detuve a muchos niños que
regresaban a casa de la escuela
dependiendo a quien detenía lo primero
que me decían era solo me detuviste
porque soy negro yo les decía conduces
un auto deportivo con una ventana
trasera así de grande no puedo ver quien
conduce y te detuve porque vas a 95 en
una vía de 55
Ahora si te trato diferente porque eres
negro Entonces soy un racista Pero si te
hago la misma bolita que te iba a dar
antes de saber quién estaba al volante
yo no lo soy me alegra que haya usado
ese ejemplo quiero felicitarlo por su
servicio a nuestro país pero quiero
decir porque de hecho he dado clases
para la pdla para sus Cadetes sobre
estos temas pero lo que puedo decir es
que una estadística y que también es un
hecho es que el 60% de nuestra población
carcelaria es afroamericana
Sí pero déjame terminar por favor son
hombres afroamericanos verdad cuando
ingresas a un sistema y te mantienen en
ese sistema y pasas por un ciclo de
libertad condicional y hay una secuencia
sistemática de opresión eso no le sucede
a los hombres blancos es más grande que
la estadística en Sí mi nombre es si era
soy actriz oradora y lista de derechos
humanos estoy muy orgullosa de ser
afroamericana de ser negra Los desafíos
que conlleva ser negro y también ser una
mujer negra son muy reales estoy un
momento de mi vida en el que Reconozco
que estas cosas son reales la
discriminación Es real la opresión
sistemática de los negros es muy real
pero lo lograré a pesar de eso
la fuerza policial es principalmente
racista
quiero comenzar diciendo que no creo que
todos los policías que existen hoy sean
racistas creo que hay muchos de ellos
que realmente están haciendo un buen
trabajo pero sé por el establecimiento
de la policía en los Estados Unidos que
eran directamente los cazadores de
esclavos que fueron contratados para
atrapar esclavos Fugitivos y traerlos de
vuelta a casa Sí estoy de acuerdo en que
no todos los policías son racistas tuve
muchas interacciones con la policía que
estuvieron bien pero un ex oficial de
policía que era un policía me dijo que
decidió que ya no quería hacer eso que
el entrenamiento es bastante
especializado solo para personas de
color especialmente negros si está cerca
de ellos son los más peligrosos Entonces
tienes que actuar en ciertas situaciones
o reaccionar de cierta forma creo que
realmente quiero enfatizar que creo que
hay algunos oficiales que son blancos
que ni siquiera creen que estén haciendo
algo malo que pueda estar motivado
racialmente porque simplemente están
haciendo lo que les enseñaron que deben
hacer
vengo de una familia de policías y me
gusta agregar que ofrecen capacitaciones
de diversidad en la academia o debe ser
más extenso O tal vez debamos dar Un
paso atrás y arreglar este proceso de
selección porque ese proceso podría ser
racista Hola Mi nombre es mía y soy
negra estoy orgullosa de mi raza porque
cuando miro hacia atrás históricamente
por lo que ha pasado la gente de mi
herencia veo donde estamos ahora y es
notable definitivamente me empuja a
seguir siendo resistente e innovadora
como ellos
históricamente la gente formaba grupos
aldeas algunas eran cazadores y
agricultores luego tenías a quien fuera
a proteger al grupo durante cientos de
años miles de años lo que sea terminamos
teniendo policías bomberos o ejército y
armadas la policía comunitaria como una
teoría es una buena idea como práctica
tiene algunos contratiempos cuando me
presento en tu casa porque tú y tu
esposo se pelearon y él te golpeó y yo
soy amigo de él soy hiero llevarlo a la
cárcel Él es mi amigo o vivo en el mismo
vecindario y
trato con un tipo que es un tipo muy
malo él dice
sé dónde vives sé dónde están tus hijos
Hasta cierto punto Tenemos que tener un
poco de separación Esto va a entrar en
un tema candente pero les diré que
cuando vi el horrible vídeo de George
les diré que puedo justificar muchas de
las cosas que sucedieron pero no puedo
justificar 9 minutos en su cuello o
espalda pero lo que también puedo
decirles es que yo como policía en eso
Esta es mi opinión personal El oficial
que estuvo sobre él durante nueve
minutos probablemente pasó demasiado
tiempo en el mismo Barrio lidiando con
los mismos problemas una y otra vez
hasta que se cansó de todo esto no es
eso lo que es ser un oficial de policía
sí es trabajo de servicio social estás
asignado a ese Distrito a esa comunidad
creo que necesitas Mo para que puedas
ver otras cosas no te agotes tanto la
policía no importa cuál sea tu raza
tenemos que estar integrados todos
juntos con la comunidad y no tiene que
ser la policía comunitaria pero todos
tenemos que entendernos más creo que la
competencia cultural sería muy útil Ese
es mi problema ya sea que los cimientos
de la fuerza policial fueran honor
racistas ahora podemos cambiar eso pero
comienza con la policía al final del día
nuestro problema son los malos policías
no todos pero los malos oficiales de
policía necesitamos exterminarlos los
buenos policías tenemos que alentarlos a
estar en la comunidad como los
investigamos haciendo que los sindicatos
policiales rindan cuentas porque me
siento como este grupo demográfico de
oficiales en realidad están empeorando
las cosas para los otros oficiales que
en realidad absoluto lo están tratando
de hacer su trabajo creo que necesitamos
obtener algún tipo de rendición de
cuentas que no creo que la policía deba
vigilar a sí misma cuando esos policías
que no cumplen su ju pueden ser
removidos en lugar de obtener todos
estos pases los policías malos odio el
término como la manzana podrida es como
no eres una granada defectuosa estás
arruinando la reputación de todo tu
departamento siento que a veces me
mantuvieron a la altura de los
estándares más altos trabajando en Food
tuve tres oportunidades afuera pero tuve
tantas 17 informes para George Floyd es
como sáquenlo de ahí Qué están haciendo
crees que los policías realmente Tengo
curiosidad crees que deberían pagarles
más
creo que a los policías se les debería
pagar más y deberían hacer menos por qué
me envían a todos los casos de Salud
Mental porque me envían a estas cosas
Ahora les diré porque me envían a ellos
porque dejaremos de enviar a la policía
allí y luego sucederá algo horrible
trágico y dirán porque no tuvimos un
policía allá crees que necesitamos
diferentes divisiones como Salud Mental
y otras o incluso policías específicos
que sean solo para las escuelas crees
que eso ayudaría a resolver los
problemas no tenemos policías
especializados en ciertas cosas Pero si
seguimos
especializándonos y nos compartimentamos
tanto que no puedo ir cuando estoy al
otro lado de la calle cuando ya veo lo
que nos ayuda Sí
eso es lo que hago Tengo que ir a buscar
al tipo que se ocupa de las mujeres que
gritan Mi nombre es Jimmy Y soy un
oficial de la policía jubilado y no voy
a decirles que no hay racistas en el
departamento de policía Ay no creo que
históricamente los negros hayan sido
tratados justamente por la ley hemos
hecho grandes progresos avances creo que
tenemos que seguir mejorando Pero antes
creo que veremos racismo hasta el día de
hoy en tal vez donde no los haya
a veces desearía ser una raza diferente
diría que no tanto en estos días pero
definitivamente 100% cuando era niña
deseaba ser blanca crecí con mi madre
blanca no había helado negro de mi
familia después de cierto punto crecí en
un pueblo pequeño a menudo era la única
estudiante de color la única niña negra
y tengo este cabello rizado no pude
encontrar la manera de trabajar con él
todo el mundo también me llamaba oreo
siempre fue solo ser otro siendo una
niña quería ser aceptada quería ser
blanca quería parecerme a mi mamá quería
lindo cabello lacio y quería sentirme
incluida era lo que quería sí recuerdo
que en la escuela primaria estaba
pensando ningún hombre nunca se va a
enamorar porque me veo así solo recuerdo
que odiaba mi cabello porque Tan pronto
como llegó la pubertad simplemente
explotó y la gente seguía preguntando
cosas como necesitas una almohada para
dormir por la noche y yo como no puedo
soportar estas preguntas
soy Jordan soy birracial creo que ser
birracial definitivamente es vivir en el
medio Porque culturalmente sí crecí
blanca y lo sé completamente fue creada
por mi madre Blanca pero también hay una
parte en la que se percibe tu raza y es
lo que la gente te pone Y cómo te tratan
en tu vida cotidiana
es muy interesante porque crecían
comunidades predominantemente no negras
y por alguna razón siendo una minoría en
el hogar en la familia así como en la
escuela y en el mundo siempre estuve muy
orgullosa de ser negra de hecho
realmente anhelaba estar cerca de otras
personas negras afortunadamente en la
universidad esa fue una experiencia en
la que aunque formábamos una pequeña
comunidad Yo decía son como yo estuve en
el ejército durante seis años y
normalmente era el único judío en mi
Batallón creo que el aislamiento me
produjo un orgullo y una comprensión de
quién soy y de dónde vengo Nunca quise
ser algo diferente de lo que era pero es
porque realmente Nunca pensé en eso para
todos ustedes tal vez no sé pero tal vez
la gente Los trató de esa manera Porque
existe la sensación de querer algo que
nunca antes habían tenido me encanta
tener un Lamborghini sabe lo que quiero
decir es diferente a cualquier otro auto
que haya tenido diferente con lo que
crecí creo que personalmente para mí en
realidad fui adoptado por padres blancos
y una familia muy diversa creo que seis
de los ocho Somos todos adoptados de
razas diferentes tengo mi propia
historia aparte de todos los demás Lo
mismo para todos que fueron adoptados mi
familia tiene su propia historia siempre
me enorgulleció pero al mismo tiempo mis
padres o mis padres sin importar los
colores sus pieles las personas que me
criaron simplemente sin mirar a través
de la raza y nunca he querido cambiar mi
raza en absoluto soy Joshua y soy negro
nunca he experimentado el racismo he
experimentado cosas de personas de mi
propia raza creciendo en la familia
blanca de padres blancos me llamaban
constantemente blanqueado me molestó
pero no me afectó ser negro en Estados
Unidos para mí es simplemente hacer
estadounidense en Estados Unidos como
cualquier otra persona
el privilegio blanco existe
América fue fundada por blancos para
blancos en ese momento todas las
instituciones fueron diseñadas para
beneficiar a los blancos por supuesto el
privilegio blanco persiste en la
sociedad actual no puedes negar eso lo
que discutiría un poco contigo Es que
creo que
desechamos el término privilegio de los
blancos con demasiada frecuencia para
cosas que no son privilegios tengo que
estar Completamente de acuerdo contigo
en eso creo que hay un privilegio
generacional de los blancos con
seguridad pero creo que ahora casi se
usa como una razón para no esforzarse
tanto si evitamos que hagas eso
trabajamos para lograrlo y no usamos El
privilegio blanco como excusa entonces
podríamos llegar a alguna parte como
comunidad negra
discreparía respetuosamente todo eso es
cierto Hasta cierto punto me gradué de
la universidad durante la pandemia el
apogeo de sí misma fui al extranjero
para la universidad tengo dos grados me
gradué con honores aprendí a hablar dos
idiomas debería haber sido capaz de
conseguir un trabajo de inmediato cierto
no me tomo nueve meses antes de poder
conseguir un trabajo tuve que salir
completamente de mi campo pero luego
cuando Mira todos mis colegas blancos
que estaban en mi programa todos fueron
contratados de inmediatos necesito
presentarte a mi hija
Ella es blanca le tomó mucho tiempo
consiguió su trabajo cuando se graduó
respeto eso pero mi punto es que
comparándome con los estudiantes blancos
que estaban directamente en mi posición
ellos fueron exitosos y yo no este país
se fundó sobre la llegada de personas
blancas y luego promulgaron Jim Crown y
otras leyes que decían que si no eres
Blanco eres genéticamente inferior ni
siquiera eres una persona algunas de
esas leyes y esos sistemas Todavía están
vigentes hoy dos cosas pueden ser
ciertas dos pueden ser ciertas puede que
lo hayas pasado mal el privilegio no se
limita solo los blancos pero decir que
el privilegio blanco no existe en la
historia para mí es con todo respeto
absurdo algo que aprendí y recientemente
es el privilegio que existe en el campo
de la medicina
específicamente en relación con el
proceso de burling en la administración
de epidurales hubo un estudio que
recientemente fue desacreditado que
decía que las personas negras tienen una
mayor tolerancia al dolor que luego ha
sido utilizado falsamente por personas
que ayudan a apoyar los partos al dudar
en proporcionar epidurales a las mujeres
negras que dan a luz y muchas mujeres
mueren en el parto no sé las
estadísticas más probabilidades de que
las mujeres negras mueran el hecho de
que me tomen más en serio que a una
mujer negra en mi lugar Si debe dar a
luz en algún momento lo veo como un
privilegio absolu Mi nombre es brim y me
acabo de graduar Y actualmente estoy
ganando horas para convertirme en una
terapeuta con licencia como terapeuta en
la escuela nos enseñaron a abordar las
cosas con lo que se llama humildad
cultural humildad cultural es ser
curioso Y en lugar de tratar de tener
todas las respuestas trabajar con el
cliente para entender De dónde vienen me
han tratado como un fetiche por mi raza
bien la estándar o Eres muy bonita para
hacer una chica Negra estoy como eso no
es un cumplido eso es tan extraño de
decir una de las líneas de piropos de
hombres para salir es como Oh Dios mío
qué eres estoy como Esto no es lindo
estoy cansada de tener esta conversación
esto apesta sí sé que tengo ojos verdes
ojos color avellana sigamos creo que las
mujeres negras en particular son
extremadamente sexua y fetichizadas
todos los días algo y me aseguro de que
mi atuendo esté bien porque no quiero
llamar cierta atención por la forma en
que llevo mi cabello si es afro si es
con pompones si es con trenzas me van a
tratar diferentes Sí sí lo harán todos
los días algo sucede
hay una forma de antisemitismo positivo
en el que se percibe a los judíos como
personas compuestas que provienen del
dinero son médicos abogados y las
mujeres se sienten atraídas por ese tipo
de cosas entonces también todos los
hombres judíos son circuncidados algunas
mujeres tienen esa preferencia
definitivamente lo he experimentado pero
siento que es algo sutil y trivial
realmente nunca me molestó Pero ha
ocurrido de todos modos
Sí he tenido experiencias en la escuela
secundaria la universidad la gente me
pregunta detenme principalmente las
mujeres les gusta o eres egipcio o eres
negro en esto negro en aquello siempre
es negro y algo más les hago saber lo
que y dicen Oh Eso es exótico
Mi nombre es Dino y soy birracial No
quiero que la gente piense que estoy
dividido entre ser negro o blanco
Reconozco que soy mixto y soy birracial
pero en su mayor parte mientras crecía
siempre me consideraron negro me
considero negro y mi familia también lo
hizo no creo que debamos vivir en una
sociedad daltónica pero tampoco creo que
debemos quedarnos atascados y sentir que
no podemos avanzar y aún así prosperar Y
lograr cosas debido a nuestro color de
piel vivimos en Estados Unidos
Solo tengo una pregunta para todos los
que dieron un paso al frente Solo tengo
curiosidad cómo es eso cómo es acotador
suena agotador sí creo que
históricamente las mujeres negras tienen
una relación muy interesante con la
deseabilidad culturalmente parece que no
somos deseados cuando lo somos estamos
siendo fetichizados es como está bien no
somos deseados pero ahora lo somos me
apoyo en la fetichización creo que solo
por ser mujer lidiamos con ciertas cosas
Todos los días específicamente ser una
mujer negra ser fetichizada es
interesante Porque si yo especialmente
en mi industria porque estoy allí para
trabajar y ser profesional Soy súper
profesional y no le doy ninguna atención
a ese ese tipo de energía entonces soy
una mujer negra enojada no puedes ganar
sí se siente así sí No creo que puedes
ganar Sí también hay otra cara para mí
específicamente soy de piel Clara entre
la mayoría de las personas de piel
oscura y la gente me considerará o
considerará a las personas de piel Clara
de cierta manera más débil o menos que o
simplemente como de acuerdo eres más
débil Así que cuando veo a Pro negros
diciendo nunca te consideramos como uno
de nosotros eres solo otro Bueno eso
toca solo los estándares de belleza en
la comunidad negra y eso es colorismo
incluso me han dicho Eres hermosa no
eres negra son esas pequeñas cosas o
debes estar mezclado con algo verdad sí
mi nombre es Cristina y soy birracial me
han fetichizado por el color de mi piel
en ambos lados los hombres negros
estarán realmente interesados en mí
porque soy de piel Clara u otros hombres
que no son negros podrían estar
interesados en mí porque soy esa chica
negra pero tal vez no soy demasiado
negra eso por la razón que sea es
atractivo ser considerado exótico o algo
así es simplemente muy problemático es
influye en muchos problemas de colorismo
dentro de la comunidad negra necesitamos
reparaciones para la comunidad negra
negra
Yo no creo que la gente necesite cheques
de pago individualizados verdad no creo
que eso vaya a funcionar pero creo que
verter fondos en comunidades que
realmente podrían usar los creando
empleos en esa comunidad más educación
más oportunidades haría mucho Así es
como creo que debe ser cada vez que las
comunidades negras en los Estados Unidos
tratan de levantarse por las correas de
las botas Son atacadas creo que fue en
Tulsa a bombardearon la ciudad el Black
Wall Street fue completamente destruido
una vez más hay que hacer algo cuando
terminó la guerra civil hubo
representantes de Ohio no recuerdo su
nombre pero era un republicano radical y
abogó por la frase 40 Acres en una mula
para cada esclavo emancipado se suponía
que iba a haber y nunca la subo creo que
especialmente como persona judía los
judíos recibieron reparaciones por el
holocausto y aún las reciben en mi mente
no hay una cantidad de dinero que pueda
deshacer el mal del holocausto que todo
el dinero del mundo Nunca lo arreglará
pero
creo que la idea y el principio de las
reparaciones es bueno logísticamente no
sé cómo sucedería
quería decir que la razón por la que me
quedé atrás fue porque no estaba del
todo segura de lo que significaban las
reparaciones pero su ejemplo del
holocausto Bueno estoy de acuerdo razón
similar cuando pienso en reparaciones
pienso en algo similar a un cheque de
estímulo mi preocupación es con la falta
de Educación financiera realmente
lograremos avances Me encantaría la idea
de invertir dinero en programas en
comunidades desatendidas algo así pero
tengo miedo de que incluso si tuviéramos
el dinero sin ese conocimiento
generacional de cuidar nuestras finanzas
sería acabar y derrotar el propósito
pero Incluso si eso sucediera sigo
pensando que ese sería el paso correcto
les daremos a esta gente los fondos o lo
que sea le estaremos nuestra promesa si
flota no se hunden o lo que sea Eso
depende de ellos al menos nosotros como
país dimos el paso correcto estoy a
favor de que el dinero vaya a la
comunidad yo estoy por eso porque las
comunidades ahora están como están por
cosas del pasado pues pero para dar
cheques a personas individuales hay una
diferencia entre aprender del pasado y
luego quedar Atrapado en el pasado si
tuviera una máquina del tiempo
retrocedería en el tiempo y diría Oye
nunca nos diste los 40 Acres y la mula
Yo estaría todo por eso me ocuparía de
eso para que las personas que se vieron
afectadas en realidad pasaron por las
esclavitud pero en la época actual nadie
lo ha experimentado ni ha pasado por
ellos sí las comunidades están siendo
golpeadas por eso pero yo nunca crees
que tus antepasados experimentaron la
esclavitud creo que sí pero yo no nunca
he pasado por eso porque debería recibir
un cheque de otras personas que nunca
puso Él debería estar yendo muy muy muy
atrasa con las personas que son
descendientes de los sueños esclavos que
podrían estar cosechando los beneficios
financieros de sus antepasados que
trabajaron como esclavos En esos Campos
generación tras generación no creas que
durante ese tiempo
mis abuelo pudo haber estado
construyendo un negocio que podría estar
floreciendo ahora tendrías una
franquicia multimillonaria mientras
quitan las espaldas a los demás no creas
que eso merece alguna rectificación para
ti ahora
ser honesto no porque de nuevo es algo
que sucedió en el pasado una vez más no
lo he experimentado estoy bien Ahora
estoy bien y no voy a estar molesto por
los antepasados de otras personas que ni
siquiera sé que esclavizaron a mis
antepasados no lo necesito no tengo por
qué tenerlo para mí personalmente no
estoy molesta por eso pero siento a mi
abuelo de su lado fueron la primera
familia en el estado de Texas en
solicitar reparaciones para mí estoy
teniendo éxito a pesar de eso pero al
punto de este caballero cuando el
gobierno dice Oye vamos a hacer una cosa
Obviamente el propio gobierno vio el
peso del error del mal al igual que el
gobierno alemán creo que si quiero
comprar cadenas de de 90 es asunto mío
creo que sería desafortunado pero creo
que si tengo derecho a algo creo que
debería ser de la misma manera que lo
obtuvieron las personas de ascendencia
judía Debería ser de la misma manera que
Los japoneses dijeron que lo
consiguieron puede pensar que no le
afecta pero en general creo que la
esclavitud nos ha afectado mucho Hasta
el momento simplemente elijo No
concentrarme en eso sin parar para que
no se convierta en algo que me detenga
pero definitivamente es algo a lo que
tenemos derecho Gracias genial gracias
Un gusto conocerte México un placer un
placer conocerlo adiós
[Música]